[Musik]
hallöchen willkommen zu einem neuen blog
von mir heute bin ich ganz alleine der
hansa geht gerade burger essen bei traum
ko ich bekommen gleicht besucher mainz
zwei schwestern ich habe insgesamt drei
geschwister ja machen wir uns so ein
schwestern abend und hatte herberger
essen hier so ein bisschen obst und
knabberzeug aber das eigentlich
interessante ist im kühlschrank
ich habe jetzt hier so ein bisschen aus
dem kopf heraus das ist jetzt ein
bisschen boden lemon gehört mit frischen
creme mit quark und sahne
hier habe ich löffelbiskuits ihn bitter
lemon getunkt und hier noch ein gruß aus
sauerkirsch saft und ich hab irgendwie
alles was ich da hatte zu einer torte
verwehrte und das hier haben wir heute
gedreht eine motiv torte total selten
bei mir auf dem kanal fand die jetzt
ganz cool und als haus des geldes fan
musste ich irgendwas in die richtung
machen
und ja das ist die zweite komplett ohne
werkzeug also komplett wirklich ich habe
nichts an werkzeug benutzt nicht mal
mein von land lebte habe ich aus dem
keller geholt sind alles wunderbar
funktioniert einige stunden später und
das ist aktuell übrig vom kuchen sehr
gutes zeichen dass man so viel verdrückt
wie ein zutritt und vor lauter kuchen
essen habe ich vergessen was richtiges
zu essen
und wir haben jetzt 21 uhr eigentlich
sollte ich nichts mehr essen ich glaube
ich gehe spazieren
beim spazieren
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt spazieren in unserer hoch
das ist um so neue homo mensch beginnt
straße ja und spaziert immer eine schöne
sache gerade wenn das wetter so toll ist
warum hätte ich so meine lieben ich habe
mich jetzt ganz gemütlich auf die couch
gehockt und werde jetzt online shopping
betreiben geht es total gerne bei source
shop und ich hab jetzt hier so einen
kleinen live act für euch wie ihr online
bisschen geld sparen können das sind sie
natürlich werbung und das werde ich auch
hier einen blinden aber dass werbung die
euch zu gute kommt und es ist halt mega
mega einfach ich als inhaberin eines
online shops findet dass gerade mega
mega interessant und bin seit einigen
wochen mit lettershops in kontakt und
ich habe mir das ausführlich erklären
lassen und bindet sogar überlegen ob wir
das mit dem kies kitchen online shop
nicht auch machen aber lasst mich euch
das ganz kurz erklären lettershops ist
eine reine cashback seite mit über 600
shops und ich zeige euch hier auch gerne
mal meine favoriten
ich gehe wie gesagt super gerne bei asus
shoppen übrigens gibt es bis zu 30
prozent cashback je nach thema welchem
anbieter ihr einkauf ich werde auf jeden
fall die erweiterung installieren als
ich das gesehen habe habe ich mich mega
gefreut denn ihr müsst euch vorstellen
der browser erkennt jetzt automatisch an
wenn ihr onlineshop welcher dieser shops
mit lettershops kooperiert und so eben
auch source hier seht ihr wie viel cash
back es gibt bei estos 321 und schon
sind wir auf der seite ich bin auch
direkt eingeloggt und kann los shoppen
so mein einkauf ist beendet ich habe
haben mir ein paar trainingsanzüge
bestellt und ein paar basics und hier
seht ihr unser cash back von 430 ich
persönlich als sparfuchs finden diese
cash back aktion immer genial weil es
nicht wirklich nur ein paar sekunden ihr
klickt euch nur einmal durch die seite
in den shop und jetzt automatisch
gesperrt ein neuer tag heute natürlich
auch wieder mit wir waren schon fleißig
haben schon ein video gedreht ist noch
die spuren hier muss ich noch alles
aufräumen wir haben nämlich pizza
gemacht und jetzt gebe nachkauf land wir
brauchen sie ein paar
an fahrrad nicht kommt einfach mit
beginn zusammen
jetzt habe ich mich kurz umgezogen und
die jetzt geht's los
cannabis soweit dein ernst
hamza dein ernst nehme ich mal was ganz
anderes das habe ich neu gekauft das ist
uralt sieht man noch umzugs spuren und
so weiter und liegt jetzt ein vater
drüber so happy home hamsa al wakrah
damit noch sonderschulen
es ist interessant dass das natürlich
ist es traurig
dann wollen wir mal
[Musik]
die wir zu hause ich wollte nämlich nur
kurz auf abholen
im moment ganz herzlich dafür dunkel
hier
hallo ansich schon wieder voll auf dem
boden angekommen weil ich das ist schon
eine integrierte zeigt aber es gibt
diesen neuigkeiten einmal richtig stolz
auf dich danke es gibt diesen
neuigkeiten das hier ist nicht nur
irgendein prospekt ist dass kaufmann
frostig das ist in meiner familie
einfach schon legendär weil wir
irgendwann mal in kauf am prospekt
gesucht und geguckt haben am
frühstückstisch und wenn mama ist auch
schon ganz stolz wenn ich zeig euch
seite 14
[Musik]
die gibt es im angebot ich bin im
kaufland wisst ihr wie ich mich vor ich
dass es für mich es sind für mich solche
gold sie drin zu sein es landesweit im
prospekt ich finde das so heftig dass
ich so stolz drauf
landesweit das ist echt mal rein
da bin ich und das ist meine aprikosen
torte das rezept habe ich natürlich
selbst entwickelt alle rezepte entwickle
ich selber ob es auf meinem thema online
kommen oder auf dem kaufland kanal dass
hier auch das ist eine logik mango tat
wir haben uns alle wieder beruhigt es
komme auf den boden der tatsachen zurück
denn ich muss jetzt trotz alledem trotz
dass sich im prospekt in mich sehr freue
muss ich jetzt wäsche machen gehen
[Musik]
mehr passiert heute auch nicht mehr ich
neben euch morgen selbstverständlich
noch mal mit also heute war ja wirklich
nur drehen kaufmann prospekt und wäsche
machen und ein bisschen haushalt machen
und morgen gibt sich gerne wieder mit
nämlich zum abend kann sich ja auch
gerne mal zeigt in dem ich noch eine
kugel tablette guck mal ist er hat
extrem tolle hände und
entzündungshemmende wirkungen und man
fühlt sich einfach viel viel besser aber
ich das gefühl man muss übrigens kurkuma
nicht das gewürz nicht das was ihr zum
würzen benutzern und so richtig bio
guck mal reingucken annehmen und ich hab
jetzt ich probiere mich da auch selber
durch also ich nehme es einfach online
bestellen wenn ihr einfach online dienst
wahrscheinlich auch in der apotheke ihr
müsst ihr immer mit einer prise pfeffer
nehmen manchmal ist es schon in der
kapsel mit verarbeiteter könnte darauf
achten und ich glaube sogar mit öl haben
sie war das somit für von öl genau mit
prise pfeffer und mit fett also haben
soll ich machen das so wir nehmen eine
tablette am tag und dann ein teelöffel
schwarzkümmelöl ich habe ja schon mal
zieht schwarzkümmelöl ist das
nonplusultra für euer immunsystem und
seit wir das nehmen fühlen wir uns auch
viel viel viel besser ich jetzt auf
jeden fall wunderschöne und wir sehen
uns mal wieder auf meinem shop account
habe ich ein ganz spontanes gewinnspiel
gemacht habe die pakete jetzt hier schon
fertig gemacht aber da kommt noch eine
persönliche karte rein da er hier ein
hinweis dass mitarbeiter den kahn das
dass die gewinnspiel pakete sind und das
lasse ich mir definitiv öfter einfallen
weil ihr euch so gefreut habt super
und jetzt geht's nach hause haben sagt
man die show gesehen zu werden heute
zwangspause wir können nicht drehen bei
diesem wetter risiken auf 37 80 33
wie andere in der schule hitzefrei haben
haben wir zwangspause kann man bei dem
wetter mit den softbox dann nach oben
die lichter überall lichter damit die
perfekte beleuchtung da genau und
deswegen lohnt es sich nicht zu viel
weil alles weg schmelzen würde und man
selber auch so teil wegschmilzt finger
mit zwangspause und ja mal gucken was
wir dann holt so schönes treiben
ja ich habe schon eine idee wir verlegen
den balkon monate davon menschen
ich mache das gerne dazu und ich guck
dir da macht keiner was
jetzt widmen wir uns erstmal dem
mittagessen ich hab das rezept
ausprobiert richtig gehört hab schon
probiert und eigentlich sollte es sogar
die polo pikante soße von papieren
werden aber das kann der handels
beurteilt der bestellt das immer ja ja
das riecht schon so und gleicht kein zu
probieren und dann wird abgefilmt aber
dann mit richtigen ruinen und anderem
gemüse jetzt packe ich meine windbeutel
torte sind 135 grad draußen aber egal
und zwar ist das meine fans sie kate
form ich habe darin schon ein paar mal
gebacken
aber ich wollte das ultimative rezepte
finden für einen richtig schönen
saftigen stinknormalen schokokuchen den
mann aber total gerne ist und ich glaube
ich habe das perfekte rezept gefunden
und da kommt jetzt noch ein bisschen
schokoglasur obendrauf
ich sehe ich mich haben wir einzelhilfe
schnell so jetzt wollte ich euch ein
kuchen zeigen müssen
und es ist im moment ich sag mal aus ich
danke dir
kennzeichnet ab dieses war passiert
hier zu 17 einsätzen in der sekunde auch
noch schon schraubt sie hat dabei grüße
gehen raus und eliane unsere ländern
übrigens fahre ich jetzt zu meiner
freundin und kann bei den freunden
gesagt männerabend ich noch mittels er
grillt und wie essen kuchen lieber
konkret beim kuchenessen ich bin zu
hause angekommen da wartet auch schon
die saubere spülmaschinen auf mich wir
haben es jetzt halb eins diesmal soll es
morgen ich bin echt müde mit kuchen ist
übrigens richtig toll geworden der
schokokuchen in meiner fans sie vorm
verlinke ich euch mal um die info-box
aber ich denke ihr wart dieses rezept
online kommt ich muss man auch jetzt
alles schnell auf schreiben wo ich meine
mengenangaben nicht vergessen dass mit
dem tablett das tablett ist aber aus
machern bis jetzt nicht wo man dass herr
bekommt er hat diese form richtig genial
auch zwischen aus kann man das tolle ist
hier das ist ein stück für mich weiß das
ist sehr groß und das sie haben soll
dass jedes wird also das ist absichtlich
so das ist nicht extra so dass wenn
katzen
ich begrüße euch zu einem neuen tag und
der hansa läuft hier so gibt es keine
thermobecher auf der welt warum
im september war ich auf der welt haben
so wir sitzen jetzt in herne bei meinen
eltern dieser mein papa besuch weil
meine türk heißen das ganz alleine der
arme allerdings erst einmal auf den
nägeln genialer film und jetzt geht der
könig der löwen haben sich nicht weiter
wird immer so emotional beim könig der
löwen
ich denke für bereuen werde heute abend
ich weiß ja nicht
[Musik]
eine popcorn instagram der film war
einfach traumhaft der war einfach
wunderschön und richtig emotional
kindheitserinnerung tour ich muss
ehrlich zugeben diese zwangspause
dadurch dass es ebenso heute sind wir
nicht filmen können es tut schon gut man
kann schon gut entspannen und muss auch
mal sein ganz ehrlich und die nächsten
zwei tage jetzt auch noch richtig heiß
das heißt da machen wir auch nichts also
mit filmen nicht natürlich geht der shop
weiter und alles drumherum natürlich
gibt es auch andere sachen zu bearbeiten
zu erledigen aber es ist halt nicht so
vollen umfang ich finde das filmen ist
dann immer das was am meisten teil
braucht es macht natürlich auch spaß ich
will das nicht negativ gehen da war es
tut auch mal gut einfach mal nichts zu
machen so wie heute das war ganz schön
und ich werde den block kids beenden die
wollten öfter blogs haben und dafür
dürfen die dann auch ruhig kürzer sein
falls ich werde ihn jetzt beenden
dann würde ich den bearbeiten kann
hoogland kann übermorgen sind wir in
frankfurt da fühle mich dann auch
nochmal und dem nächsten blog seht ihr
dann auch so ein bisschen wie das die
aktuelle aussieht meine couch ist
angekommen dem balkon werde ich anfangen
so ein bisschen um zu räumen und zu
verschönern und dass wir auf jeden fall
richtig richtig spannend
also keine sorge sagte der haben sei der
im pyjama herumläuft und sich so nicht
vor der kamera seien ja haben sie gesagt
gerade man kann bei dem wetter ähnlich
schlafen ich bin so müde leute aber ich
weiß es wieder so eine schlaflose nacht
sein wird naja egal luxusprobleme gibt
schlimmeres im leben
also ich wünsche euch jetzt noch einen
wunderschönen tag und schreibt mir auf
jeden fall lässt man auf jeden fall
kommentar da ich bin immer so gespannt
was sie zu den blog schreibt bei den
rezepten natürlich auch aber bei den
blogs ist noch mal so ein bisschen was
anderes lasten auf jeden fall ein
kommentar da schreibt mir was so eure
gedanken sind und dann schaltet auf
jeden fall im nächsten blog eines wird
mega mega mega spannend also bis dann
lieben